[MUSIC PLAYING]
REZA ROKNI: Good
morning, everybody.
Thank you very much for
coming along and giving us
some of your morning.
My name is Reza Rokni.
I am one of the
solution architects
here at Google, currently based
out of our Singapore office.
And part of the
solution architect role
is to try and find new
and interesting use cases
to apply for our technologies.
And one of the things
I've been able to do
is work with a few
banks, including Neil,
and Reuven, who I'm
going to introduce now.
So Neil, if you want
to introduce yourself.
NEIL BOSTON: Hi,
I'm Neil Boston.
I'm head of IB
Technology for UBS,
and I also run UK Technology.
So I run wealth management and
asset management out of the UK
as well.
REZA ROKNI: And Reuven?
REUVEN LAX: My
name is Reuven Lax.
I'm a software engineer
on Google Cloud Dataflow.
REZA ROKNI: And so the
project that we've been doing
is making use of data flow,
which is our batch and stream
processing system to
do grid computing.
And we've done some
pretty interesting work
with building out some demos and
some near realistic scenarios.
But to just describe
what grid is and then
some of the challenges
and opportunities,
I'm going to handover to Neil.
NEIL BOSTON: Thanks, Reza.
So I'll just talk through
maybe three or four
slides very briefly.
And it's from a very
personal perspective
as well, so if you
agree or disagree,
please come and have
a chat afterwards,
and we can debate
some of the points.
What is grid computing?
I guess, to me--
not to read the words
exactly, but basically
having a large cluster with
a set of nodes that we're
going to do some kind of
analytic calculation with,
is generally the way
that I approach it.
Now that could be
deterministic stuff
that I've coded in myself,
could be elements of ML as well.
But basically, I look
at it as a large cluster
of calculation agents that
are doing some set of tasks.
Generally, hopefully you can
make them relatively stateless
and do it in a relatively
independent way,
so when you aggregate
and bring the data back,
that could be thought
up and thought out
in a relatively
straightforward manner.
So as with most
things in my life,
I started with three wishes.
It's not asking for
infinitely many wishes.
It's not what a wish is.
Or a large but finite amount
of wishes is one of the wishes,
I guess.
So when I approached
and talked to Reza
and we were discussing
this, I guess in London,
it was actually in a pub when we
first started talking about it.
REZA ROKNI: As all good
engineering projects in London
are.
NEIL BOSTON: As all good
engineering projects in London
are, near a place
called Farringdon,
which was very good,
I started writing down
what my users'
stories were, but they
became three wishes basically.
So I wanted to write single
threaded simple calculation
class as functors or packages.
I didn't have to worry about
things like multi-threading,
for example.
I wanted to stop thinking
about creating my own
directed acyclic graphs,
bitemporal or not.
I just basically wanted to
focus on my IP and my analytics
in a very simple way.
But I like to be able
to tweak my experiments
and run my experiments in
a much more seamless way,
rather than having to
recompile and rebuild
a lot of my analytic classes.
So I wanted some environment
I could basically
drop my functors inside,
run a set of experiments,
get set of results out,
and do that repeatedly,
either manually or through a
set of machines, potentially.
So three simple wishes, I guess.
Challenges.
I guess, I've been in markets
technology for 150 years now,
so a long time.
So quants, I wanted
to really focus
on my quantitative analysis,
people writing maths.
I just wanted to focus on
the maths and the outcomes
rather than thinking
about this whole fabric.
So over the years I've
been in markets technology,
you can spend 20% of your time
thinking about the mathematics
and 80% of your time thinking
about how you make this thing
scalable, how you make
it distributed, how
this thing can scale.
And actually, one of the
challenges as well is you
can spend a lot of your time--
I guess my background is C++--
is trying to optimize your
C++ code to run on your PC,
which is obviously
diminishing returns of scale.
So again, I wanted to try
and get away from that.
I wanted the people to
focus on the mathematicians
and physicists and
engineers, to focus
on running experiments,
rather than thinking
about the other aspects about
the ecosystem, and much more
about the maths, the data
coming back and the outcomes,
and analyzing that,
either manually
or, again, through machines.
And I wanted to be able
to do it very, very fast.
So if I didn't know
which model to choose
and I had a category
of models, to be
able to get to some reasonable
outcome in a relatively
quick way by running
experiments at high velocity
was really the challenge.
So kind of utopia, I guess,
from a of quant prospective.
Opportunities, running it on
demand and also event driven.
There are two sides very
much in markets technology.
I want to sometimes run things
at very large scale and lots
of things, which you'll see
later in the experiment.
But I also have things
coming in at high frequency
that I want to
deal with as well.
So you can think of as a
bifurcation a little bit,
but you don't want a bifurcation
in ecosystem or fabric.
I want to be able
to run a universe
of parallel experiments and
then do some assessment of them,
either through some
parametrization,
through some MLPs,
or again, manually,
just looking at these
things in a reasonable way,
and then run huge, I
guess, simulations.
So if you come from banking
and have a look at the way
the market's gone,
especially with regulation
in recent years, running
large Monte Carlo simulations,
for example, [? onport ?]
entire portfolios across all
the markets that the investment
bank of the markets division
has is, again, a
significant challenge.
I'll talk about it
a little bit later,
about the organizational
issues that you
have around some
of the technology
choices the banks make
to try and accommodate
some of those solutions.
But again, regardless of
the simulation experiment,
I wanted a relatively stable
and consistent ETL style
environment that I
wasn't too worried about.
Now I'll hand over to Reza, and
he can talk through Dataflow.
REZA ROKNI: Sure.
And so this is interesting,
because Dataflow
we use predominantly in
things like ETL pipelines.
So we're taking data,
we're processing it,
we are passing that on
to things like BigQuery.
So why are we using
this for grid computing?
To look at this-- and this was
after many conversations when
we were sitting down and
storyboarding this stuff
and looking at architectures--
you kind of have to
deconstruct what a grid is,
and then it makes
perfect sense why
Dataflow is a very good tool
for solving this problem.
So what is a grid?
First of all, it's data.
It's a bunch of math
functions, so smart maths
folks like these guys.
You need lots of
CPUs, and you need
some way of scheduling
jobs on those CPUs.
So you need to get data
and functions to the CPUs
and get them to do the
work, and you need storage.
So let's go through those
in a little bit more detail.
And we start getting
into why Dataflow
is particularly useful here.
So in terms of data, there's
quite a few data sources.
First, there's internal
data sources, so the trades,
et cetera, that are
happening within the bank.
There's a lot of
information there.
There's external data
sources potentially
from market environments, all
of these raw underlying data
that we need to then
do some processing.
And then there's derived data.
So this is data where you've
taken underlying information,
you've done some
processing on it,
and you've got some new data
that you need to distribute,
for example, yield curves
that are iterating based off
of things like swaps
and deposit information
that you have early on.
Now the next piece
around data is
that it doesn't come
in a nice, static file.
It's streamed.
It's continuously being updated.
Again, this is starting
to get interesting
in terms of what Dataflow
is capable of, which
is being able to do stream
processing on that datasets
that are coming in.
Next, it's functions.
It's maths functions.
It's a lot of CPUs.
One of the interesting
challenges, fun bits,
we had is a lot of the quant
code that's been written
in the last 20 years,
I guess, is C++.
And Dataflow today does not
support C++ as a standard
language.
And we had to do some work,
and I worked with Reuven to get
Dataflow flow to
run C++ code for us.
So that was a little bit of fun.
NEIL BOSTON: So I
was just going say,
I guess the 3.1 wish is I
didn't want to JNI into the C++.
I wanted to think of it
in a much more, I guess,
natural way.
So I guess that was my 3.1
wishes, rather than just three
wishes.
REZA ROKNI: And I found out
from Reuven that actually,
C++ is the original
Flume, right?
REUVEN LAX: Yes, so
internally at Google,
we do run a version
of Dataflow on C++.
There was just-- at the time
we came out with Dataflow,
there wasn't as much of a
cloud market interested in C++.
Most people were interested
in Java or Python
or other languages.
REZA ROKNI: So we
basically made--
retrofitted C++
running on Dataflow,
even though the original
FlumeJava was all C++.
The other piece around this
is kind of that ETL work.
So you're having to munge data.
You have to shape it, enrich it.
And then once you've
got that data,
there's a place of storing it.
You need to then store--
pull from storage within
the pipeline itself.
You may potentially need to
do output to storage as well.
And these grids
have huge fan-out.
So I can take a couple of megs
worth of market information,
or even, let's
say, a gig, and it
generates terabytes of output.
So we need some way
of actually being
able to deal with huge fan-out
from these environments.
And then there's one
secret ingredient
that actually means that
one of-- the testing we've
done so far has been
very, very productive.
And that secret ingredient
is the movement of data.
So if you think about the
fact that we're pulling source
information, we're doing ETL.
Then we're sending that data
to the next stage, which
is doing the processing
with that data,
so running those
maths functions.
And then we're sending that
data again to the storage.
These are all chunks
of data movement.
Now with Dataflow,
we can actually
create a DAG, a distributed--
a Directed Acyclic
Graph, sorry--
of computation.
And those connections between
all of the nodes, Dataflow
takes care of moving
the elements for me.
So this is, again,
why we started
thinking, actually,
Dataflow is a very
good fit for this environment.
And when we think about
this movement of data,
one thing I noticed, because I
don't actually originally come
from a finance
background, was you
see a lot of organizational
structure coming
into how the DAG is created.
So by that, I mean there's a
team that does some ETL work,
and they generate a file.
This file is then moved to the
team that does the grid work.
And then the grid work
outputs another file,
which is moved to the team
that does the analytics work.
And what that is
doing is essentially
creating this
organizational structure
on top of how the
technology should look,
but that's not
really what you want.
What you want is one
continuous operation
from beginning to end.
And Neil will explain this in
better detail than I could.
NEIL BOSTON: So I
guess this slide here,
this schematic, it's not
specific to the banking
industry.
But the way that
I've perceived it,
over many industries
over the years, is they
tend to design technology
by organizational construct.
So what you tend to find
is people within group
A, B, and C will actually
have a view about how
their world looks.
And maybe they have
specific user stories
that are giving them some niche
aspect to the design patterns.
Well, what they tend to
do is build the ecosystem
above and beyond their
own boundary conditions,
and then hand over the
data or the information
to the next group.
So then you end up in data
translation and ecosystem
translation, and
then reconciliations
and that style of problem.
So again-- and it hits--
like I said, it's not just
our industry specifically.
There's other industries.
But I think it can be that
people then start thinking
about technology choices.
Rather than actually
thinking about what's
optimal for their solution front
to back or from left to right,
more about thinking about how
their organizational construct
is driving that.
So again, one of
the things that I
wanted to challenge a
little bit was that we
don't need to think about--
when we think about
it in an evolution
or a revolutionary
sense, I guess--
is to think about how
we can offer something
out that actually crosses those
boundaries naturally and has
a very integrated stream
based and batch based approach
as well to the problem.
REZA ROKNI: So a little bit more
about BEAM now, and a better
person than me to
describe it is Reuven,
one of the technical leads
who built BEAM, and Dataflow,
the [? runner ?] for BEAM.
REUVEN LAX: Yeah, thank
you, Reza and Neil.
Oh, thank you for the clicker.
This use case is very
interesting to me,
because as Reza mentioned,
I think a lot of people
see Dataflow as an ETL tool.
It's a very common use case to
use Dataflow to get your data
into files or into BigQuery.
But Dataflow is actually
a programming model,
and it's a programming model
that fits this grid use
case very well.
You divide your logic into
massively parallel computation
with its stateless functions.
And then at key points,
you also put aggregations,
where you need to bring the
data together to compute a count
or to write it out to BigQuery.
And the key to this
is, as Reza said,
this data movement, which
is one of these things that
sounds easy.
You just have to
move data around.
And it turns out that
writing a system that
can move massive
amounts of data,
at scale, efficiently,
with strong semantics,
never moving an element twice,
never duplicating an element,
is surprisingly hard to do.
And integrating
that all together
is one of the advantages you get
out of Dataflow that makes it
work really well for
systems like this.
So the way we have Dataflow
designed and presented
is as a three layer system.
So we have APIs.
Currently, we have a Java
API and a Python API,
and we have more APIs coming.
So there is a Go API,
which is usable today
in an early access.
There's also a
SQL API, so you'll
be able to write Dataflow
pipelines entirely in SQL.
Then there's this programming
model I talked about.
All these APIs just live on
top of this programming model,
and then multiple runners
to run your pipeline.
So there's the
Google hosted runner
called Google Cloud Dataflow.
This is this fully
managed runner.
We just point it at
our cloud and it runs.
We also have open-source
runners, one on top of a system
called Apache Flink,
one on top of a system
called Apache Spark.
So your Dataflow
pipelines are not
bound to only
running on Dataflow.
So this is interesting
in the hybrid cloud case.
We've also found in the
financial services industry,
this has been interesting
to some people
for regulatory reasons.
If a job needs to
be rerun on prem,
if a regulator
requests it, it can
be done with one of these
open source runners.
So what is the advantage of
the Cloud Dataflow system?
So Cloud Dataflow is one of
the runners for this BEAM API.
So Cloud Dataflow just presents
this fully managed, no-op
serverless solution.
So you don't have to--
the SDK gives you a nice, simple
API to develop these things.
But then Dataflow
manages security for you.
It manages the cluster for you.
You don't have to spin up a
cluster to run your pipelines.
It will auto-scale
your pipelines.
So Dataflow will attempt to
learn how big of a cluster
you need to run your
pipeline, and it will actually
shrink and grow this
cluster over time.
As you get towards
the end of your job
and there's less
data left, Dataflow
will just start
shrinking the cluster
and try to optimize cost
as much as possible.
There's also a lot of
integration with TensorFlow
based machine learning models.
So there are TensorFlow
APIs that you can integrate
inside your Dataflow job, and
there's a suite of TensorFlow
based transforms that
you can run via Dataflow.
So there's a suite
called TFX which
is a suite of machine
learning transforms
for prepping and evaluating
machine learning models.
So a classic
example of that is I
trained a new machine
learning model,
and I run a simple
analysis on it.
It says, OK, it's 5%
better than my last model.
Then you deploy it,
and you find out
that, oh, it was 5%
better on average,
but it was producing
worse results
for everybody from the state
of Florida, for instance.
This is actually
not a better model.
So it turns out
evaluating these models is
fairly tricky to make sure that
the model actually is better.
TFX provides suites
of tools to do things.
That's one example of the
tools that TFX provide,
is good evaluation of models.
And this all runs on
top of Cloud Dataflow.
So I mentioned that Dataflow
lets you run serverless data
analytics, as opposed
to other clusters
where you have to run a cluster.
So what is the benefit of
serverless data analytics?
Well, if you look, this
little chart on the left
is traditionally what
you would have to do
to run your big data analytics.
So there's a tiny little
piece of your work
in which you actually
worked on your analysis
and your insights, your
business logic, your functions,
the actual quant stuff that
Neil wants his people to spend
most of their time working on.
And then you would
actually spend about 90%
of your time on everything else,
building a monitoring solution
to make sure your job is
running, performance tuning,
figuring out how many workers
do I need to run this on?
How much memory should
I give each worker?
What particular type
of worker should I be?
Should I run on
four core workers?
two core workers?
Should I run on 16 core workers?
Then making sure my
utilization is up to snuff.
Then figuring out a deployment
story and a configuration
story.
And people would often
spend a huge amount of time
coming up with
different deployment
stories for these systems.
Resource provisioning,
handling growing scale.
So I came up with
something that worked,
and then suddenly, six
months later, my input data
is 50% larger.
The thing I came up with
before no longer works.
Resetting, going
back to the start,
and running through this
whole process again.
Reliability,
setting up alerting,
making sure that these
jobs actually run reliably
and complete, as I expect.
The advantage of serverless
is to cut out all of this pie
except for the
analysis and insights.
Focus on the actual
business logic
you want to run
in your pipeline,
and let the serverless
system, in this case,
Google Cloud Dataflow,
handle all the rest for you.
And finally, we've been
saying that Dataflow not just
a product.
It's a platform.
And Google Cloud
platform is the platform
that Dataflow is part of.
So a platform is actually
not just one technology.
It's a group of
technologies that
often act as a substrate to
build higher level systems.
So as Reza's going
to show you here,
an interesting thing
here for this problem
is not just Dataflow,
but how can I
use Dataflow in conjunction
with BigQuery and in conjunction
with Google Cloud Storage, and
use all these things together
to provide a solution?
And since Dataflow flow
has sources and sinks--
as we're going to show here--
Dataflow has sources and sinks
to all these other GCP stores
and data resources, Dataflow
provides a great substrate
to link all of these
things together.
So with Dataflow-- so you
have sources and sinks.
You have an API,
which, in this case,
is the Dataflow API, which is
your way of linking everything
together, saying
read from this data,
run these transforms over
it, write to BigQuery,
write to Bigtable, write to
Spanner, write to Pub/Sub,
write to whatever
other sink you want to.
And your pipeline
is declarative.
And this image here is actually
an example of a Dataflow graph,
in fact, I believe the one
that Reza will show you
in a second of running data.
And now Reza?
REZA ROKNI: Yeah, so--
if I can have the ticket.
REUVEN LAX: Oh yeah, sorry.
REZA ROKNI: Thank you.
So just a couple of things
around the other bits
of technology we use.
I, when I was doing the
experimentation with Neil,
I don't actually have access
to UBS Bank's data, obviously.
I have to work in
my own environment.
And we wanted to make
this as real as possible.
I didn't just want to make
synthetic data, especially
for the inputs and
the ETL layers.
So what we were
using was BigQuery.
Now BigQuery is Google's
petabyte scale data
warehouse in the cloud,
fully managed and serverless.
One of the key aspects that
I was making use of here
is that it separates
processing from storage,
which means sharing of
data is very, very easy.
And this meant I
could get access
to external data sources.
In particular, Thomson
Reuters were very kind
enough to provide me data.
So they have a store
in their project
where they're putting
historic tick information
and current tick information,
including things like swaps,
deposits, et cetera, which I
need to use to build things
like yield curves.
They also, four
POCs, they can put up
to 20 years of historical
data on to BigQuery.
And I get the benefit
of just instantly being
able to use that
stuff without having
to move it around projects.
So again, thank you,
Thomson Reuters,
for helping me do this.
If I can-- one of
the other pieces
that we won't show you
in the demo right now,
but we will be using in
the real thing, is today
I'm actually sending even
the raw data to BigQuery,
like very granular data, just
so I can show it to you guys.
But in the real
production system,
we'd send outputs,
the results, which
is still many billions of rows
of information, to BigQuery.
But the raw data
that we want to keep
is going to be many,
many terabytes.
That, I would send to Bigtable.
Bigtable linearly scales,
and we use it internally
within Google for solving
exactly that kind of problem.
And it's perfect for
this environment,
because we have many
thousands of cores,
all running, generating data.
And if we don't want
to create a bottleneck,
we can just use Bigtable
and linearly scale it out,
and have all of those
cores just push data
directly into Bigtable at
many, many tens of thousands
or hundreds-- actually,
hundreds of thousands of QPS.
So with that, Neil
is going to walk
through what the
pipeline's actually doing
in terms of the finance side.
NEIL BOSTON: Yeah, so I guess
based on the 3.1 wishes,
I set up a very
basic experiment.
I mean, I don't know how
much background you have,
I guess, in investment
banking and markets piece,
but basically, the most basic
experiment I could think of
was the source market
environments or market data.
So that could be things
like FX spot or yield curves
of volatilities.
Take a portfolio,
a set of trades.
In this case, we
just randomly created
a million option trades.
Basically, take that
as our underlying data.
Process it, as you can see here.
Apply some transforms to the
market data, which is really--
you can select a
set of market data.
You then have to apply--
in this case, we used an
open source quant library
to produce a yield
curve functor, I guess,
at the end of the day, an
object, from the input.
Process the data.
I also wanted to
create scenarios.
So what I mean by
that is in the market,
you tend to have a set
of points coming in.
You also want to
shift things around.
So you could end up with a
curve with 10 points on it,
for example.
And I want to shift each
point independently,
and I also want to do these
parallel shifts as well.
So you can see I wanted to
try and create scenarios
on the fly which I
thought would be good just
from an experimentation
point of view.
Then I wanted to run a set of
analytics on it, some of which
I coded in, which is very basic.
And then analyze the experiment.
So this was kind of the
most basic experiment
I could think of.
I could choose a different trade
set to make it easier to price
and easier to risk.
But again, it was just
personal bias and preference
that I wanted to try options
from a personal perspective.
So based on the 3.1 wishes, this
was the most basic experiment
that I thought we
could start with, just
to see what that looked like.
Scenarios, again, I just chose
very market standard things,
non-parallel shifts, weighted
shifts, independent shifts,
and parallel shifts, again,
to create a much larger set
of output datasets, more in line
with what I see in the market.
REZA ROKNI: Thank you.
Could we switch over
to the laptop, please?
So we have a good problem
to have with a demo.
So we had timed this
so that it is actually
doing the scenario running while
I switch over to the laptop.
Last night I was working
with one of our performance
engineers from
Dataflow, and it's
made it a little bit too fast.
So what you won't see
right now is this stage.
And I'll talk through
what that's doing.
You would have seen the
numbers going across here,
but it's already zipped past it.
I'll walk through what
we're showing with now.
So what I have here is
the monitoring interface
for Dataflow, so the graph
that I've built in code.
I've submitted a job.
At the point I submit the job,
there's no machines running.
Everything is cold.
By submitting the
job, Dataflow starts
spinning up the number of
workers that I've enabled.
It starts sending my
code to the environment,
and it starts doing all of the
sink and source information
that we need.
So in particular, here
on the right hand side,
we see information
about the job itself.
It's still running,
because it's now
pushing the output to BigQuery.
We can see that it spun up 1,000
workers, and in this instance,
it's using 4,000 cores
from our environment.
Dataflow does
support auto-scaling,
so we can actually
let it bring up
the number of machines it
needs and then bring them down.
I deliberately don't
use that, because I just
want to make this run as fast
as possible, which introduces
some potential inefficiencies.
But for this demo, we're
just like, start with 4,000
and keep going with
the full 4,000.
A little bit more information
here, so we have--
able to in my code, put custom
counters that actually tells me
what's going on within
the environment.
And it is tightly integrated
to things like Stackdriver.
So you can actually
have monitoring
going on while your
big jobs are running.
You can see where
things are getting to.
In this particular instance, we
were sending a million trades,
and the number of scenario
trade combinations
comes out to a 847 million.
So not quite the
billion, but that's
our next set of experiments.
A little bit more information,
these are some of the options
that I am sending in to the job.
So if we look at the
DAG itself, so I'm
doing some reading
of the information.
So there's the
market data that I'm
reading from Thomson
Reuters' information.
We have some swap data.
If I expand this out, what
you can do within the code--
each one of these
boxes generally
corresponds to a transform.
And I can collapse logical
things together within my code,
and what you see there
is like, for example,
we can swap [? OIS. ?] We can
swap [? USDOIS. ?] These are
all being put into
a single transform.
The way I've done
this isn't how we do
a production version of this.
We just have it read
swaps, and I just
use code to do the
different things
you need to do for all
the different data types.
But I just used this
for good illustration.
So this is the read stage.
If I highlight every
single element here,
we can actually see
the input and outputs
of each one of these stages.
Now I'm going to move down and--
sorry, I'm not using the
touchpad on this device.
One thing that we did as an
experiment that's worked out
quite well is rather
than have the trade flow
through the DAG with
introspection to the data
sources for all the data that
they need, I reversed this.
So what we have is all of
the trades come as a lump,
as a side input.
I do all the ETL and
processing that I
need to do, including scenario
generation, from the top.
And then what I do is, because
the introspection would have
been lots of long RPC calls--
not long, fast-- but RPC calls,
which are still expensive,
what I do by bringing the trades
and all the scenarios together,
I just do a really dumb
massive fan-out with a loop.
So what it does, it just
generates huge amounts
of data tuples.
So the data that I
need to run, which
includes all of the values
from the yield curves,
for example, which is an array
of two and half thousand,
in this case, doubles--
I generate all these
values and just let
Dataflow do what
it's good at, which
is move lots of data around for
me and distribute that work.
So here we have
the trades that are
being read coming
in from the side
and being added in
as a side input.
So if we wanted just to
explain a little bit more
on what side inputs are--
so if you think of kind
of like a broadcast join,
if your data is of
a certain size that
will fit in the environment,
rather than do a shuffle join
where we're joining all
the elements together,
you just take this-- it's
like having a smaller table.
We take that smaller
table and just
make it available to
all the environments.
And then when my
scenarios are coming in,
because all that data's there,
they're just looping through.
And any trades that happen to
match the currency that I'm
looking for come out as a
fan-out of the scenarios.
So here we have the
scenarios being generated.
I actually do a little
bit of optimization,
in that for each piece
of work, we actually
make it 100 scenarios that
needs to be processed,
because it's a bit more
efficient in the next stage.
Here we have-- this
is Neil's code.
So this is C++ code
running in Dataflow.
Neil has written a--
I'll let him describe it,
because I have no idea.
NEIL BOSTON: Well, I guess
basically, I took the--
I don't know how familiar
you are with options pricing.
There's nothing
particularly smart about it.
Black and Scholes
wrote a paper in 1973
on how to price options.
They managed to show that
it was like the diffusion
equation, which is like a
partial differential equation.
So all I did is
write a thing called
finite difference for a way of
discretizing and solving that.
But ultimately, all I'm really
doing in a C++ is doing matrix,
sparse matrix, solving
calculations over time.
So it's nothing particularly
smart if you look at the code.
It's probably the least smart
piece of the whole ecosystem,
I guess.
REZA ROKNI: Well,
that's what he thinks.
I tried to read it.
NEIL BOSTON: I also took
16 days as well to run it.
These were the biggest
out of all that as well.
REZA ROKNI: Well, that's where
the real work happens here,
right.
And this was a good--
we use that function
as something
as a good indicator of what
a real thing would look like,
because it's doing real work.
And this is where
most of the work
is happening for
this environment.
So up until now,
we've been doing ETL.
We've been setting
up all the scenarios.
I've been doing these
joins and distributing
this massive fan-out
of work, which
generates, as we can see from
the output of this, 847,000
results.
Now what we do next is we
go to push this information
into BigQuery.
And if you'll notice,
the number of elements
multiplies quite a bit.
What we do is, the code
that Neil has written,
he's got a spot index,
which is actually
the thing we really want.
But he also has an array of
information, which is the--
NEIL BOSTON: Yeah,
so basically, when I
do the matrix calculation,
which iterate over time
to some answer, you get
basically a vector back,
based against
different spot levels.
But I actually want
the one in the middle,
because that's the
current spot level.
REZA ROKNI: So that's
the thing we wanted,
and that's the thing we
should send to BigQuery.
However, we want to reco--
one of the advantages of being
able to use this data platform
is at each stage
of the pipeline,
I can output results and
go back and look at them.
Because I don't care
about the IO, right.
It's just, Bigtable
will deal with it.
So what we do here
is, I'm actually
taking all of those
values as well
and dumping them into BigQuery.
Now I did that so you guys
can see it in BigQuery.
In a real production
system, the spot index
is what we take to BigQuery,
because that's what
you're going to do analysis on.
The other values I'd
write to Bigtable.
So if you wanted to go back
and check your results,
you just go to Bigtable.
And then Bigtable, you
can do really fast index
and range scan lookups.
So here I'm writing
14 billion pieces
of information,
rows of information,
to BigQuery at the end of this.
So this is the pipeline running.
It's now finished its work.
I can know it's
finished because--
REUVEN LAX: Actually, it looks a
bit closer to 15 billion to me,
Reza, 14.9.
REZA ROKNI: OK, OK, he's
the engineer here, right?
NEIL BOSTON: And
the mathematician.
REZA ROKNI: So-- and
I'm outnumbered.
So I'm just going
to show the results
as they landed in BigQuery.
So this point is another point.
When this finished,
there was no file
that I then now need to load
into my analysis system.
When this finished,
it's all done.
I can immediately run
a query with BigQuery
against that data.
So this is actually
using a different table,
but just to show the principle
here, we have grid results.
The details is 14 billion
rows of information,
which actually equates
to 1.6 terabytes of data.
That's been loaded
in this table.
And what I'm going to do--
not particularly smart--
I'm just going to say, given
the trade number was 8876,
give me the max spot index
across all the scenarios.
So when I run
this, it's actually
going through and doing
a query against all the
14 billion rows of information,
and I have my output.
So right at the end,
you can actually
start exploring your dataset,
or generating the reports
that ultimately-- we're not
doing this all for fun, right.
The bank is actually
running this
and want reports
at the end of it.
We can immediately start
running the reports.
Another thing that
you can explore with
and we started to do--
so with Datalab, which is a
notebook that we can do Python
coding against the data
sources, because all
the intermediate stages
of the calculations
are being stored in
BigQuery, what I did is just
did some exploration
with a notebook
and I've stored
it here as a PDF.
Essentially, what
we're doing is looking
at all of the information
that's available
for the whole pipeline.
So here, this is
some underlying data
that I had from the Thomson
Reuters environment datasets.
I've graphed some
of this information.
This is what some of
the underlying data is.
I actually had a look at
the yield curve creation
to make sure that
stuff's looking OK.
And one of the things--
so this is the asset and the
new numery of the things that I
will send onto the C++ code.
Both are being graphed.
One of the interesting things
here is-- this is the numery.
And if you notice, most
of them are at the top.
There's one weird one.
And this was an accident by me.
One of the scenarios,
I typed 0.5
as the amount I want things to
shift instead of 0.05, right.
And by looking at
this, I immediately
know something's weird, right.
Something's wrong.
And this is, again, something
that the data scientist
would then be able to
use throughout the output
of the results.
Now I'm just going to
go right to the bottom
and let Neil start
explaining this piece.
Essentially, this is
looking at the result sets.
And Neil was
interested in trying
to start looking at
how we can show this
in three dimensional space.
And so Neil?
NEIL BOSTON: So
I guess the thing
that I was trying to get to was
that I'm a big believer in just
looking at a set of results
as well, to see just things
that you can see visually.
So when we went down the line
of running the experiment,
then I asked Reza
if there was stuff
we could put on top
to actually start
visualizing what
this thing looks
like versus various outputs.
And when we looked at this,
I was interested to see--
we were adding up the PVs,
I guess, the Present Value,
of a lot of these trades.
So it seemed like they were
relatively canceling out.
So actually, when we
looked at the portfolio,
we realized we hadn't randomly
created buys and sells.
We had done roughly half
buys and half sells.
So they were tending
to kind of net
out in some option
sense, which is
kind of interesting
in itself and we
thought about the
portfolio we'd created.
So some of the talks
that I actually
saw yesterday the with some
other groups, there were some--
I guess ultimately, they
really resonated with me.
I was trying to get to almost
like having a single inquiry
box where I could type a
set of asks of the data.
Is this a correlation
against this?
Does this looks like
[INAUDIBLE] volatility-wise?
How does this look
against this over time?
It seemed to me
that it was always,
this was kind of evolving, a
visual representation of almost
like a single inquiry box.
And I saw a couple
of demos yesterday
where they had that style of
approach, and a little bit of,
I guess, almost like an
LPO over the top as well.
So you could type in quite
market specific language,
and it would give you back a
set of results around that.
So I thought as an
inquiry, marrying
that to this style
of experimentation
output would be
quite a strong thing.
So this was really
just a very basic--
I tend to plot
time, against spot,
against PV, against other
things in a very basic way,
just to start looking at what
the nature of the portfolio is.
But then given the couple
of days I've been here,
there seem to be some--
already some evolutions
that I was thinking of
around how we could start
analyzing the data in
a more effective way,
and asking questions
as well in a much more
fluid, experimental
sense as well.
REZA ROKNI: Thanks, Neil.
Could we go back to
the slides, please?
Go back to the slides, please?
Thank you.
So just in terms of creating
the pipeline, in that one,
we showed the
preprocessing stages,
the running of the stages,
the post processing stages.
And the semi joke here is
one pipeline to rule them
all, right.
We don't create
separate processes
for each one of these things.
We just did one, and it went
from the beginning raw data
all the way to the output,
including analysis.
And one of the other--
so the other thing
that we wanted to do
was one of Neil's first wishes,
is I want to experiment.
So as we now have this DAG
to be able to do processing,
the other thing we wanted
to do is break apart
some of the larger, more
monolithic quant code
and see if there are
linear components in there
that we could distribute again.
And Neil and-- I'll let Neil
and Reuven do some of this.
NEIL BOSTON: Yeah, so
again, it was something
that I guess I should have
thought of over my career
a little bit more
intensively about.
When we go into
this sense that we
have to stop worrying so
much about the ETL piece
that we were running here, and
the simulation and ecosystem
piece, we could
then start really
thinking about where
there are parts,
certainly within the code base
we were writing, that we could
actually look at in
a more linear away
from a parallel
processing perspective.
And again, even when
we were starting
to look at that, the
solution that we've just
been talking about, that
even had other implications
that I hadn't expected, where
we started looking at the way
that we could break these
problems apart from what we've
seen in the past,
just as someone
writing some quantitative code.
REUVEN LAX: This
is a common thing
we've seen as people move
from their old systems
to new systems, is
people have code
that was written assuming
I'm running on one machine.
And it would be highly
optimized in ways
that make it very difficult to
parallelize, like oh, sometimes
I'll spin up threads and
then join on these threads,
or interleave many
different functions
throughout my calculation.
So it sometimes requires
people to rethink
how they wrote the code, or
maybe on a mathematical sense,
look at your functions,
say, can these functions be
[? linearalized ?]
as a combination
of multiple other
functions, so that we
can parallelize all
these things out
and get a finer result later?
REZA ROKNI: And so what
that means is that when
you're drawing out the graphs,
the more access me as a data
engineer has to the
various functions
and being able to
split them apart,
the more I can try
and think of ways
of optimizing the flow and the
parallelism within the system.
So the more I can have
separate functions
that I can pass
data to and from,
the easier this becomes for me.
And this gets another--
an interesting point
that we found very
useful when we
were doing this
project together,
and that's how we
talk to each other.
So as you could tell, I
have no idea half the time
what Neil's talking about
when he's doing the maths.
It's not my area, and
neither is the finance area.
However, when we break
the problem down,
for me as that
engineer, to bytes--
so he can tell me, I need
these bytes to move from here,
and I need to run this
function against these bytes.
This output needs to move here.
When you start breaking
this down into a way
that I understand, it
becomes very easy for us
to start communicating.
And one of the things that
we used as a common language
is protobufs.
So we started talking
in terms-- so protobufs,
I'll let Reuven do
what protobufs are.
REUVEN LAX: Yeah,
a protocol buffer,
it's a common structured
format for data
that has been used at Google
since probably around 2001,
2002.
So it's been used at
Google for quite a while.
It's very similar to other
forms of structured data.
So some people use Avro.
Some people use Kryo.
Some people use Thrift.
There are other forms
of structured data.
Protobufs are an optimized one
that Google has traditionally
used and is also open sourced.
REZA ROKNI: And that
made it very easy
for me to start
working with Neil,
because I could just give
him a definition of how I'm
going to pass things
through, or he
could give me the definition.
And then I know
what I need to do
in terms of doing this process.
And the other thing it
opens up is this ability
now to actually break
apart the functions.
Because if all you're passing
as the parameter to the function
is a protobuf, and
within your code,
you start just using protobufs
to pass the information around,
when you break apart
the big pieces of code,
it becomes very easy to
plug it into the DAG,
because all I'm doing
is sending protobufs
across those nodes and that data
movement that we talked about.
So with that, next
steps, as we said,
running C++ on BEAM
is not standard,
so we got an example that
allows you to do some of that.
I'll be updating that code a
little bit more after this.
Please have a go, and thank
you very much for your time.
[APPLAUSE]
NEIL BOSTON: Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]